I want to know is it true that Jennifer
helped you with some of the Fashions to
understand the Fashions of that era and
yeah you know I mean the listen it's
brilliant and helps me in every
conceivable way and this this whole
process really has been a a
collaboration with this entire cast The
Crew the group of people you have to be
open to as far as as I'm concerned all
the good ideas you could possibly get
and that's really what I um that's
really how I approach this and I you
know work with really brilliant
filmmakers I'm a Chris Tucker Violet
Davis Marlon Wayans Matt Damon Christmas
Cena I mean it's just uh Jason Bateman
all of them brought something to the
movie that was their own and it was a
real collaboration that's what's what's
so uh what I'm so proud of about this
movie and this company ours Equity that
we're starting what's the plan we build
a shoe line around just him I need the
greatest basketball shoe that's ever
been made who's the player
Michael Jordan the movie is brilliant um
but Sonny Vaccaro's not that good
looking of a man Matt did send me a
favor but we
we did um
put I wanted to put Matt in a bodysuit
put some weight on him and we shot him
with the lens that expanded his face a
little bit make him look a little bit I
know it sounds like like it was not like
a goofy like you know Instagram you know
filter prank thing but it was I felt
like you know audience are so accustomed
to seeing Matt Damon as the kind of
Jason Bourne can't lose gonna win no
matter what and I wanted to try to
create more of that sort of Underdog
feeling you know tell me about the wig
and the tights those tights all the
clothes that I wore were that was the
most closely historically documented
stuff I wasn't going to put anything on
I was like we got to make sure there's a
photo of Phil Knight wearing this is the
80s Nike stuff that was the gear that
was hot in 84 that was the that was how
you did it yeah Captain what do you
think I mean that's that's a good look
it was back you don't know that I don't
know my kids my son rocks it looked all
the time like that so he loves them oh
yeah man okay real quick you have
Unstoppable coming up what can you tell
me about that how that's going uh
Anthony Robles is a an amazing guy who
who was born with one leg and Aaron was
a walk on Arizona State ended up winning
uh national championship in wrestling
and uh his mother not unlike this film
played a really important role in his
life he had some coaches that were
really meaningful to him and it's it's
an incredible story but it's not like
artificial or cheesy or fake it's really
moving this is an incredible guy uh we
have a great cast coming together I'm
really excited and you know we've got a
couple of other movies in the pipeline
so so far so good last thing 25th
anniversary of Goodwill Hunting I mean
when you think back oh it makes you old
it was
great great film that you made at such a
young age what do you remember as you
think back
you know I remember uh
being too young to understand or
appreciate it and it makes me think of
actually of this movie and the feeling I
have here where I really can appreciate
this I'm so proud of it and and I think
you know really this this film is an
homogenous way to uh Dolores Jordan and
moms like her who are there to kind of
be guiding forces with you know young
people who come in and get a kind of
success very early on and that's a lot
to navigate and you need somebody to
look out for you and obviously had the
greatest actor in the world there so
[Music]
good